you
a fever is an illness caused by a virus
that is delivered to the body by a
mosquito it's spread by several
different types of mosquito but the main
mosquito that spreads said has evolved
from ancestors that bred in tiny rain
water filled tree holes and so as a
consequence this mosquito can breed
wherever there are tiny collections of
freshwater and that means wherever there
are humans so we had a meeting here in
UCL about 30 people from Yale and UCL a
group from Queensland in Australia the
beginning there was a little skepticism
how the hell are we going to do this but
at the end of two days we had an
enthusiastic team from both sides with a
four-point plan of what we're going to
achieve over a couple of years to try
and solve this problem the most exciting
thing about it is that there were
several people there in fact most people
there who hadn't worked on thinking
before but we're bringing expertise from
other fields such as structural biology
and medicinal chemistry and that's the
hardest thing to do in science which is
to get people working across disciplines
in areas they haven't worked in ever
before get them really enthusiastic and
fired up about it and I think they were
and I think that there's a real momentum
now behind the project the Yale working
group complements the UCL working group
by providing additional expertise yurga
Lotus is an expert on dengue virus entry
into cells and he's working with David
Farrelly and Paul young develop
antiviral strategies to block that
process that whole process is driven by
a protein called the envelope protein on
the surface of the virus of dengue virus
and what and we're intensively studying
that protein and try to find its
vulnerabilities and and just try to
understand its behavior and how it how
it manages to drive this virus entry
process Ruth Montgomery and Mike Jacobs
are both working on
how the virus avoids what it's called
innate immune response which is how
cells respond to viral infection and
induce an immune response so in my lab
we focus on immune responses in humans
particularly to viruses like West Nile
virus and dengue virus so dengue and
West Nile are very closely related but
they give a different infection in
humans but we feel that by studying the
immune response we're going to be able
to gain some insight into dengue from
the West Nile system you're trying to
understand why some people will have a
severe infection and some people will
not even be aware they were infected my
laboratory is studying the basic
mechanisms of dengue virus replication
and in particular how one of the viral
proteins is involved in that process and
by developing inhibitors for that
protein we hope to develop drugs that
will prevent any replication if the
project is successful it would mean that
the yellow cell collaborative has
produced a new treatment for a disease
with no treatment and if we can combine
that with immunization with vaccination
then this is just a dream at the moment
but perhaps one could eradicate dengue
fever from the world
you